all right for this week's classic
interview the topic of Medicare for all
or some system that would get care to
everybody regardless of ability to pay
was popularized it was really sort of
mainstreamed by Bernie Sanders in 2016
many of the 2020 Democratic candidates
are now talking about this and we did a
neck an interview with a really
knowledgeable expert on the issue back
in 2012 okay this is how far ahead of
this thing we were in 2012 isn't even
early all right but from the point of
view of a show doing this stuff in depth
we were doing this 2012 and earlier and
in 2012 I interviewed dr. Carol Paris
and that's the topic and particularly
relevant today note the language that
was used in the interview with Carol
Paris compared to the language that
we're using now different language but
still talking about very similar ideas
let's get right to it dr. Carol Paris is
joining us she's a psychiatrist in
private practice in Maryland also a
member of physicians for a National
Health Program dr. Paris it's great to
talk to you I think a good place to
start will be to get your sense of why
you think a single-payer national health
care program would be would be a better
thing than we have now but also I'd be
curious to hear why some of your other
colleagues other doctors aren't
unanimous in that in that idea if it is
if it is beneficial as I believe you
think it is well thank you for having me
on the show yes I do think that it is
beneficial and there's lots of
statistics we can talk about or not to
support why it is beneficial both for
physicians and most importantly for
ninety five percent of the Americans in
terms of just economically advantageous
to them not to mention giving them
comprehensive coverage but why do I so I
think it's it's beneficial both from an
economic standpoint and and from a moral
ethical
you know healthcare is a human right
perspective but even if you you know
even if you don't approach it from that
perspective just from an economic
standpoint it is superior why do I think
other physicians aren't on board with it
well actually fifty nine percent of
physicians that were surveyed back in
2008 and remember that's even before the
Affordable Care Act you know 2009
legislation that said that they thought
that a national health program would be
superior and that was up 10 percent from
five years earlier that was published in
the annals of internal medicine and just
if you look at the numbers of membership
in physicians for a National Health
Program our membership increased by
three or four thousand physicians in
2009 simply because there was so much
more awareness of the problems with our
healthcare system even though there was
not a great deal of public media
awareness of single-payer as a an option
so let's talk about that a little bit I
mean I think on this program we talk a
lot from the patient point of view why a
single-payer system would would be
better but as a practicing physician I'm
curious what your thoughts would be
about well how would that allow you to
provide better care or would it would it
affect how would it affect the income of
the average physician I mean go into
that a little bit oh I'd be glad to I
got into this as I said I joined PHP in
2009 and that was after I had spent four
or five years with our state med the
Maryland State Medical Society and I was
very active in this state medical
society and I was quite proud of a piece
of legislation that I got was
instrumental in getting passed that was
designed to get the insurance companies
on one particular issue to play fair
and when it was all said and done when
the regulations were written they were
written by the insurance companies and
there's no fine for violating the law
and and it was at that point that I just
said you know there's there's just
something wrong with insurance companies
no matter what we do they will find a
workaround they will find a way to get
around any legislation that you pass and
that's what I got involved in in
physicians for a National Health Program
and started looking at putting a dollar
sign on what that would mean me and my
own practice and one of the things that
I came across was an article in Health
Affairs that suggests that the average
primary care physician the cost to the
average primary care physician is 68,000
so we're around sixty eight thousand
dollars a year per physician per year
just as the cost of dealing with
multiple insurance companies okay so
this takes into consideration if I
understand the average primary care
physician I don't know what numbers
you're using is it a slate of about
2,500 patients that they have kind of on
their roster I don't know what the
number of patients is this was published
in Health Affairs edition but the idea
would be that the average position with
an average patient load because of both
billing and timing put in to working
with insurance companies would stand to
save sixty eight thousand dollars if
that bureaucracy was eliminated that is
correct
okay now as far as as far as care is
concerned does it just follow that
simply by not having to deal with that
you're providing better care well I
think usually you have people working
and on the billing side so I don't know
that that's the argument but how would
it translate to better care well
actually the people that I have working
on the billing side are medical
assistants they could actually be doing
blood pressures and weights and action
things that would be good for my
patients rather than answering phones
and chasing prior authorizations so from
that perspective it would be good for
the patients plus if I don't if I'm
getting a raise
simply by not having to spend have so
much overhead go into dealing with
multiple insurance companies then I
might actually be able to see a couple
fewer patients a day and spend more time
with the patients that I'm actually
seeing which definitely translates into
better care I think if you ask the
average patient what their feeling is
about the amount of time that their
physician spends with them I don't think
you're often going to hear that that
patients feel like their doctor spends
as much time as he or she need or at
least from the person's perspective that
the patient feels is necessary and I
don't think that's because doctors don't
like to spend time with patients it's
because we're like hamsters in a cage
unless we see a volume of patients every
day we can't pay the bills we can't pay
our staff and have any money left over
for an income so on the last end of this
I guess my question would be about as
far as and this is probably a issue that
has multiple influences both the fear of
lawsuits but also what insurance
companies will and won't cover which is
that of necessary or unnecessary tests
that are often done we just did a piece
a couple of weeks ago about a number I
think it's 45 different tests that a
group of doctors came together and said
you know these are really overdone and
if people did them less you know in
specific conditions we would actually
eliminate a ton of spending at the same
time a lot of the reason that those
tests are being done is because doctors
both need to cover themselves and know
that if they're not done and documented
future procedures may not be covered so
talk a little bit about how the the
diagnosis and testing might change with
a single-payer health care
well the argument has made the doctors
do so much of the testing because
they're afraid of being sued right right
and so when you think about malpractice
and you look at what when you break a
malpractice award down the majority of
the money in any malpractice award is
for is to cover the patient for future
medical care hmm
well guess what that goes away if we had
a National Health Program because that's
already assured you get your Medicare
card the day you're born and you lose it
the day you die
so necessarily every malpractice award
is going to be significantly reduced if
we had a National Health Program which
then translates into a smaller premium
for your malpractice insurance because
the payouts are not what they used to be
which again translates into more income
for doctors and fewer malpractice claims
because the majority of the reason that
people pursue a malpractice claim in the
first place is because they need to be
assured of continued care and if they
don't have to be assured of continued
care then if it's one of those cases
where it really wasn't malpractice but
well but it's equivocal and the
patient's not is is going to have
expensive care for the rest of their
lives that goes away with the National
Health Program okay I wish we had more
time we've been speaking with dr. Carol
Paris she's a psychiatrist in private
practice in Maryland also a member of
physicians for a National Health Program
really great to speak to you and we'd
love to have you back again thank you
very much